jump very quickly to Zagreb with Maurice
Ashley and a special guest we are with
women's international master Ariana
Kohli who just happens to be the wife of
Levon Aronian first of all area and you
are here with Levon now you just got
here and you mentioned off air man I had
to come on the day when he's playing
black against Magnus how does that feel
your your husband is a professional
player and you yourself being a great
player who can follow the action was it
like how nervous that you get thanks
Maurice great to be here I wouldn't say
I'm a great player but I am good enough
to be nervous enough but you understand
that when he thinks a lot in the opening
it's probably not nerve-wracking but you
know he's a professional so he does this
every day so we just got to tell
yourself that in calm down tell us you
yourself you are doing a lot of things
you're the managing director of your own
firm Akron Capital is a policy and
economics yeah and also an advisor to
the head of the Armenian government
that's and that must be quite an
interesting job well it's it's we do
work mostly with government clients and
different funds around the world so yes
it's very interesting Maurice what's the
experience like you were born in the
Philippines you lived in Australia you
played of course we're both Olympic
teams and now you're in Armenia where
where LaVon is simply a chess God and
what is it like having that experience I
guess it feels like a natural
progression because I I've always loved
chess it's in my blood I love it and I'm
now in a country that adores chess and
not only adores chess adores my husband
so it's amazing and you know you wake up
every day and you meet people and I go
actually just this morning I got
messages on Facebook saying oh you know
levelin is the next world champion he's
playing the world Chinese Day but you
know he's the next one I get messages
like that all the time and it's really
encouraging and you know it's very sweet
yeah you did something recently that was
absolutely amazing stunning when you
first told me we were going to do it and
now you've done you did a two thousand
one two thousand kilometer bike tour by
yourself
yeah across several countries tell us
about that oh it was it was amazing it
was to raise funds for the children of
Armenia fund which so we built schools
and they teach chests in those schools
by the way yeah this is in regional
Armenia and so I did 2,000 kilometers
across 20 days averaging 100 days a day
by myself I'm the only person in history
to do it so we started in Turkey on the
Mediterranean all the way across Turkey
and different me let's say pockets of
ethnic conflicts and then through Iran
all the way through Iran and then to
Armenia so I yeah it was I'm very proud
of that actually thanks for bringing
that up and it was it was a lot of fun
and I think the central message besides
the historical context and how
interesting that was was to drive home
that you know sport and chess is really
important for kids you were in a biker
before that you were telling me I was
there for you know I know what was it it
must have you did youdid vlogs on it as
well what was that light to be going
through that kind of arduous physical
experience when you were not when you
were not that was your profession itself
I think the training was awful I
remember my first training I just got
home and I just collapsed on the floor
my dog was like looking at me I wanted
to vomit it was awful but then you know
you pushed through and I think that's
the point so throughout my whole life
I've tried to do things that challenge
me like boxing even different things
mountain climbing I've done a few
mountains as well so in Iran and in
Turkey and Ankara and so I think that's
important so even if you don't know
about it that's fine just deal with it
and the whole concept is to like grow
this mental toughness and that's what's
important and I think that you got to
put those kind of goals in front of you
and so yes it was it was horrible and I
wouldn't recommend it if you don't have
that you know mental toughness but at
the same time I think it's a good way to
train that to put those kind of goals in
front of you simply remarkable very
admirable tell me you I know also used
to dance quite a bit you know I'm into
salsa bachata you also dance salsa
tell us about Livan skills oh he's awful
now
you know he's very passionate about
salsa and he knows the music really well
and he loves dancing but he's a terrible
dancer
but I do know that you teach him a bit
when he's in st. Louis oh we went out to
a club and he kind of stayed on the side
and kept drinking and watching and never
went out to the dance floor I was trying
to pull him onto the floor but I think
he just analyzing the situation well
maybe cuz I wasn't there but I've got to
make sure that happens
you also mentioned girls initiatives in
chess which i think is your your near
and dear and passionate it is well it's
I haven't really done anything concrete
in that direction but I think in the
future I would love to be it's not an
advocate or someone involved in in
something that you know chest for girls
but especially related to the point that
I that I talked about earlier which is
about mental toughness and I think chess
really teaches that you know as a chess
player you know I'm just a woman I am
but I think most title players they get
into the workforce and they're always
asked you know how does chess translate
to real life and for me the answer is
mostly not but yes when it comes to
mental toughness you know in boxing you
get knocked out and you get the instant
feedback and you get some physical
damage as well but in chess it's more
mental and I think you can start from an
early age and you know especially girls
they I think it's the best way to gain
confidence and that kind of thing not to
be intimidated no you're not someone who
gets intimidated easily and you say just
just the woman I am that's absolutely a
great accomplishment not an average
accomplishment in addition to all the
many things you do thanks so much for
joining us good luck in the game today I
know it's gonna be tough watching him
play Aryan Coley women's I am managing
director of her own firm and biker or
salsa dancer you name it this lady is
incredibly accomplished welcome to our
show and that's those are the kind of
people that we see in the chess world
all the time thank you